The Gruesome Tale of Lady Bluebeard
You probably remember Bluebeard, the title
character in the French folk tale by Charles
Perrault, which you might have stumbled across
in a fairy tale book or two.
Bluebeard was a man who had been married several
times, but no one knew what had happened to
his previous wives.
When he takes on a new wife, she discovers
the murdered bodies of the old wives in a
small, forbidden room.
It’s the kind of thing you hope will stick
to the storybook pages, but for one Belle
Gunness “The Lady Bluebeard,” that was
not the case.
Gunness was virtually unknown before she immigrated
to the United States from Norway between 1881
and 1886.
There is a story that she was beaten by a
man while pregnant at the age of seventeen,
causing a miscarriage and a distinct personality
change.
Supposedly the man died shortly thereafter
with symptoms akin to those of poisoning,
but there’s little documentation to support
this.
Nevertheless, the incident could have been
what spurred her to move to America… or
it’s possible that she simply moved to be
with her sister, who had emigrated some years
before.
Whatever the case, Gunness met the (first)
man of her dreams in Chicago, where they married
in 1893.
His name was Mads Ditlev Anton Sorenson, and
he didn’t know it yet, but he was going
to be Gunness’ first known victim.
Together, the seemingly happy couple opened
a confectionery store and had four children
together—Caroline, Axel, Myrtle, and Lucy.
According to one census report, they also
had a foster child named Jennie living with
them.
A year after starting the confectionery store,
business wasn’t so hot.
That is, until the building caught fire and
Gunness and her husband were able to collect
insurance for the “accident.”
It’s possible that Gunness actually started
the fire, or that collecting insurance gave
her the idea to collect more insurance from
other sources.
Over the next few years, two of their children,
Caroline and Axel, died officially from acute
colitis.
However, many of the symptoms of acute colitis,
such as abdominal pain, are in line with the
symptoms of poisoning.
It’s possible that a doctor, unwilling to
believe that a mother would poison her own
children, didn’t look into the two deaths
as well as he should have.
Both Caroline and Axel had life insurance,
and the insurance company lined Gunness’
pockets after her tragic loss.
As for Gunness’ husband Sorenson, he died
in 1900—conveniently on the one day that
his two life insurance policies overlapped.
There are a few different theories about how
he died, but officially it was recorded that
his heart gave out.
The doctor attending him originally thought
he was suffering from strychnine poisoning
but was later convinced not to look into it;
the death wasn’t considered suspicious by
most (though Sorenson’s family requested
it be investigated, their demands were never
met).
Gunness was paid $8000 dollars (about $217,000
today) in insurance money.
In 1901, Gunness used the money to purchase
a farm in La Porte, Indiana.
Shortly after the purchase, part of the property
burned down and, you guessed it, she collected
money for it from the insurance companies.
A short while later, Gunness met the (second)
love of her life: Peter Gunness.
Mr. Gunness was a recent widower with two
daughters.
The pair married on April 1, 1902, and the
three Gunnesses moved in to the farm house
with Mrs. Gunness and her two remaining daughters
from her previous marriage.
Unfortunately, bad things tend to happen to
children when Mrs. Gunness is around, and
the younger of Mr. Gunness’ two daughters
died shortly after the wedding from “unknown
causes,” though it is known that she passed
while she was in Belle’s sole care.
In December 1902, Mr. Gunness himself met
a terrible fate when a meat chopper fell on
his head, killing him.
Foster daughter Jennie arrived on the scene
shortly after and saw Mrs. Gunness sobbing
over his body.
Anyone suspicious yet?
Jennie apparently was.
She was overheard saying, “”My mama killed
my papa.
She hit him with a meat cleaver and he died.
Don’t tell a soul,” which prompted an
investigation into Mr. Gunness’ death.
The coroner was at first convinced that he
had been murdered, but was later persuaded
by Mrs. Gunness that she hadn’t done anything
wrong.
As she was pregnant at the time, it’s possible
that she used her condition to underline how
innocent and harmless she was.
Gunness later cashed in on $3000 (about $81,000
today) from Mr. Gunness’ insurance policy.
She gave birth to a son, Phillip, in May 1903,
adding to her brood—Jennie, Lucy, and Myrtle
remained in the house.
Mr. Gunness’ elder daughter was taken away
by a kindly uncle who likely saved her life
by getting her out of the house.
Not happy without someone to prey upon, Gunness
put a personal ad in some big city papers.
It read:
“comely widow who owns a large farm in one
of the finest districts in La Porte County,
Indiana, desires to make the acquaintance
of a gentleman equally well provided, with
view of joining fortunes.
No replies by letter considered unless sender
is willing to follow answer with personal
visit.
Triflers need not apply.”
Many men did answer her ad.
They came bearing gifts of cash, such as John
Moe who brought $1000 to Gunness to demonstrate
his wealth, and disappeared shortly thereafter,
never to be heard from again.
To the people of La Porte, it simply looked
like Gunness had a lot of suitors, and no
one was entirely surprised.
Even with age and filling out quite a bit,
Gunness was considered a beauty with her blonde
hair, tall figure, and shining white smile.
Yet all of those disappearances couldn’t
go unnoticed in her own home.
Jennie, who had already proven something of
a liability after the death of Gunness’
second husband, suddenly disappeared in 1906.
Gunness claimed she had been sent to a finishing
school in Los Angeles, but the girl was never
seen alive again.
In 1907, Gunness was seen with a man purchasing
an expensive wedding ring in town; he soon
disappeared.
Later, she won the affections of Andrew Helgelein,
a poor misguided fellow who withdrew all of
the funds from his bank account before meeting
a similar fate.
However, Gunness was starting to run out of
luck.
All of her suitors had people who cared about
them, and sooner or later they traced them
to Gunness.
Andrew Helgelein’s brother was particularly
interested in his brother’s whereabouts,
and wrote to Gunness to enquire after him;
she replied that she hadn’t seen him before,
but Asle Helgelein still decided to travel
to La Porte to investigate.
He arrived too late.
On April 27, 1908, Gunness could be found
writing up her last will and testament, claiming
that she feared for her life because her ex-handy
man, Ray Lamphere, was deeply in love with
her and extremely jealous of her suitors.
That same night, her house burned to the ground.
Inside the house, four bodies were found:
three children, presumed to be Lucy, Myrtle,
and Phillip, and the decapitated body of a
woman.
Ray Lamphere was arrested for murder and arson,
but there was some speculation about whether
or not the body of the woman was actually
Gunness; without the head, the dentist couldn’t
check dental records, and the shape of the
body seemed too small to be Gunness.
That’s when the whole morbid tale began
to unfold.
Items like watches were being found in the
rubble of the Gunness house, and Asle Helgelein
showed up alleging that Gunness was a “gold
digger” who was murdering men and taking
their money.
The sheriff remained unconvinced, so Asle
took it upon himself to ask Joe Maxson, the
Gunness’ most recent handyman, if Gunness
had a place where she dug holes for things
like cinders.
The answer was a place near the hog pen—which,
incidentally, had an unusually high fence.
Asle grabbed a shovel and started digging.
He ended up finding his brother, the most
recent of Gunness’ killings.
His body had been chopped up and stowed in
flour sacks.
They found several more bodies, one of which
was quite obviously Jennie, who hadn’t gone
to California at all; the theory is that she
got suspicious of the suitors leaving in the
middle of the night and was going to raise
the alarm.
Around twelve bodies were found near the hog
pen; it could have been more, but with so
many body parts, it was difficult to tell.
The digging continued, and more and more bodies
were found in the fields.
Most of the bodies were never identified,
but reports flooded in from relatives of missing
people who believed their loved ones had made
their way to La Porte before meeting their
untimely demise.
Lamphere, who was found guilty of arson but
not murder, later admitted to helping Gunness
bury the bodies.
He claimed that she had murdered 42 people
all told.
She would give her victims a nice meal and
then drug their coffee; after, she would sometimes
smash their heads with a meat chopper.
Other times, she would simply poison her victims.
After dissecting them and chopping them into
pieces, she buried them in the yard or fed
their remains to her hogs.
As for Gunness, a lot of evidence points to
her escaping the fire that killed her children.
Lamphere claimed he lured a woman to the house
where she was killed and her head was chopped
off.
Gunness then drugged her children, killed
them, and left them in the house to burn.
She took off, never to be seen again.
Whether or not Lamphere was to be believed,
Gunness’ bank backed his story, saying that
Gunness had withdrawn nearly all of her money
the day before the fire.
That, combined with creating a will shortly
before her supposed death, made people suspect
that she had intended to fake her own death
and skip town.
However, Gunness’ dentures were found in
May of that year, convincing the dentist and
some of the townsfolk that she had indeed
died in the fire.
That said, the skull wasn’t recovered.
Many people remained convinced that she was
still at large somewhere, living off the fortune
she made from her victims.
Her death was never confirmed and she was
never tracked down.
Numerous sightings were made around the Chicago
area, but none of them were confirmed.